So, let's recap this section really quick. We can be exposed to stressors, and
they can be both pleasant and unpleasant. Like a vactions or a marriage, or
death of a loved one. And both stressors can produce negative emotional
responses. And sometimes, these negative emotional responses can be difficult
to control. And when we encounter a stressful situation, we engage in primary
appraisal, which is our first reaction or assessment of a situation. However,
upon experiencing a negative emotional response produced by the stressful
event, we can also engage in secondary appraisal. Secondary appraisal is using
our self assessment and looking at the resources available to help us cope with
this stressful event. By engaging in secondary appraisal, we may be able to
reduce the level of negative emotions that we experience. So, in the shower
handle example I showed you, it nicely demonstrates how I perceive the primary
event as very, very stressful. But upon my secondary appraisal, I was able to
lower my stress levels, because I realized how happy I was that the handle
didn't break off while the water was still running. I knew I really lucked out
with that one. I also realized the things I needed to do to make the problem go
away, such as calling the plumber. And this a way of coping with the situation.
So, this again demonstrates that it's a person's perceived ability to deal with
a stressful event or stressor that results in a negative emotional response to
stress. If however, I was a handy plumber myself and a shower came off, I
wouldn't perceive the event as stressful at all. I would just fix it myself,
because I would have the skills I needed to solve the problem. Now, I might
still be a little stressed about the things I need to do to get the handle
fixed, but not as much as I could be, because I figured out how I want to solve
the problem.